oh yeah this is my talk the immersive
web in 2019 and there's a lot to the
and also 20 and a team just started so
it's gonna be a weird talk so the meat
of this talk is actually going to be pre
2019 and how we got here and I want to
talk a little bit about so before I talk
about the immersive web I want to talk
about just the web in general so if we
go very far back the web sort of started
everything I'm going to talk about today
is gonna involve the 3d web in the
immersive web but if we think about the
web as it started it was basically just
built for text documents and then we got
CSS level 1 and all of a sudden we could
do fancy things like style or buttons
and make make you know navigation bars
and that was fun and as things have
gotten progressively progressively more
advanced with high fidelity we've
started to do really let's say
questionable things like adding parallax
to every single page and creating you
know hiring somebody hiring an animator
to create a flash intro for your page
right like the web has always has been
progressively sort of adding more and
more visual fidelity as the years of
Warner have worn on and if you've ever
wanted to sort of completely break out
of the 3d context you would need to go
through WebGL and if you're not familiar
with WebGL
it's basically an API that operates
through the canvas API and it sort of
gives you a graphics context it's a
little square or a rectangle or whatever
shape you want it to be and it says okay
you control all the pixels here and you
would you most people don't program in
WebGL directly they use a helper library
so this is a gif of a few examples from
a three Jas which I'll be talking a
little bit more about for the rest of
this talk but yeah so if you've ever
wanted to sort of get into 3d on the web
it's always been very manual and you
even with these helper libraries it sort
of feels like you're playing in a
different environment
it doesn't feel sort of native to the
web and that all started to change
would say when Google cardboard was
first announced back in 2014 so this is
the first time that WebGL had been
hooked up to a to sort of a device so if
you have never if you've never
experienced sorry to a device that had a
gyroscope so if you've never experienced
Google cardboard um you would put your
you put your smartphone into landscape
mode and it would sort of display one
screen to one your left eye and one
other screen to your right eye and you
would put it inside this little like ten
eight dollar cardboard box with two
special lenses inside which are really
just like shiny pieces of convex glass
and you are concave glass and you would
all of a sudden move your head and be
able to see into whatever the whatever
the sort of the WebGL display was
showing you and this is really cool
because even though it wasn't sort of
like quote-unquote true VR you were you
were able to take a web page or people
you were also able to do this through
apps but a lot of web pages were
designed for this because it was a
really novel use of the gyroscope api
which up to this point like hadn't
really been used in web pages and it was
sort of the beginning where people were
talking about okay actually now like
mobile devices or computer desktops can
actually be used for for VR specifically
and VR is this this idea where you do
you do basically this right it's like
putting on a blindfold and as we're
gonna see VR is not the only sort of
like way to like change your reality but
if we even while so back in 2014 is sort
of when things were like I guess
starting to heat up for the second time
for they are so if you wanted to the
Google cardboard experience was really
nice but all you could do was three
degrees of freedom rotational tracking
and what that means basically is all you
could do is look left and in turn or
return your head around this way
if you moved your head in at all you the
the camera the view that you were seeing
wouldn't move with you you would need a
rig like this with an HTC vive or an
oculus rift tied to like a very you know
like three thousand dollar computer with
a very special graphics card in order to
interpret you know all the positional
movements all the hand movements and
order sort of keep keep up to date the
graphics drivers that this sort of like
really intensive VR system was running
and so this is still really nation days
for web VR but this was basically the
impetus for it it was that okay cool the
web can do you know sort of like toys
stuff with moving a gyroscope using your
smartphone but we want the web to sort
of as a platform be able to handle be
able to handle a sort of full scale true
VR and be able to expand even beyond
that so there are a bunch of ways to
sort of get started with the web via our
API you can go through it directly you
can use three J s or you can use just
raw WebGL if you would like but I've
personally always used this library
called a frame and so this isn't gonna
be a this talk isn't about a frame but
this is just a quick little demo that
sort of lets you see how accessible web
VR has gotten over the past few years so
I don't know if you can read this super
well but this little this little tag
here says a dash spear and it's
basically a custom web component that
the a frame library defines and you said
you can do stuff like a dash sphere and
you give it an attribute called a
position and it moves it in Xyz
coordinate space and you can even assign
it a color which changes it's sort of 3d
property 3d material property and you
can do this for a bunch of different
assets and you can as long as you put
them all in between these tags a scene
you get something that looks like this
so that mark up the
that you know eight seven or eight lines
that on the previous slide turned into
this and it's fully interactive so this
is an example of what it looks like on a
desktop you can sort of drag around and
move using your arrow keys but if you
had a computer that was hooked up to a
VR headset you'd be able to press a
button and it would automatically jump
into the context if you were using a VR
browser of your compatible browser like
experimental builds of Chrome or Firefox
you'd be able to press the button and it
would sort of all of a sudden be able to
interpret your controller movements and
your head movements and sort of do true
VR and on top of this you can it also
you can also see from here it like
degrades really gracefully to the
desktop if you were on a phone and you
had a Google cardboard with you you
could do Google cardboard mode but even
if you don't have the cardboard with you
you could also just use your normal
gyroscope and sort of wave your phone
around and it's it's basically it's like
a really weird experience for sure like
I'm not gonna say that it's like the
most optimal thing but it's really cool
that sort of you have a way to reach
everyone even if they don't have access
to a very expensive very nice piece of
VR equipment so yeah so that's sort of
that that work with web VR has been
progressing for the last few years and
but people were sort of hesitant browser
browser implementers were sort of
hesitant to implement the web via our
spec as it was defined because people
had been focusing on VR specifically and
everything was sort of tied to that use
case it assumed that there was no camera
input assumed that it seemed a bunch of
different things about position and so
there there's a few problems with this
one is that sort of mobile AR is now a
thing that people know about and I'm
basically going to give all the credit
for this to Pokemon go because even
though this wasn't the highest fidelity
a are people still sort of got a taste
of what it meant to go to you know go
outside of in your living room is one
Pokemon on the beach is a different
Pokemon
and sort of there's that you know
macro-level location-based changing but
also you could see the camera input over
the game input and that was that was so
even though there was nothing it wasn't
really used to great effect it sort of
gave people an idea that games could be
played spatially spatially and
immersively using just devices that they
already have which is their smartphones
and then on top of this using devices
that not everyone has the hololens was
officially released for its first dev
kit in march 2016 and the magic leap was
officially released just August of last
year for its first dev kit as well and
both of these are really important
because they're they're a are headsets
so in the same way that the true VR
headsets we're sort of the test of
whether or not we could do whether or
not we can do sort of the immersive web
for for VR these AR headsets
now give us a chance to see things like
a frame or 3GS or just raw WebGL running
in a completely transparent way over the
real world so things are just overlaid
and you can sort of see it's not like
putting on you know the Google cardboard
blinders you can actually stay in the
context of your living room or you know
go out into the real world and sort of
interact with it naturally but so that's
cool like it's cool that sort of we have
progressed beyond VR and that this is
sort of becoming feasible but as this
post called progressive WebEx or which
is on the mozilla VR blog points out
this is a lot of things there's a lot of
there's a lot of new considerations here
so the post so the post is called
progressive web excite which is sort of
like tagging sort of leading on in the
tradition of progressive enhancement
so whereas progressive enhancement you
know a upgrades or web pages
capabilities depending on what device
you're on this sort of changes the way
that the web page is displayed based on
what sort of immersive
our capability you can have so XR is
basically just like a like meta acronym
for AR and VR together and in its its
web XR because this is all we're focused
to just on websites but instead of just
having a desktop or just having a mobile
version now you can have a mobile AR
version or you can have a mobile VR
version or a true VR version or
eventually write like an AR headset
version and so there's a lot to keep
straight here and I think it's it's good
it's good that we're beginning to
develop methodologies around how to sort
of how to how to work around all of
these all of these sort of constraints
and out of this the web via our API
itself has been renamed to the WebEx our
device API and the working group that is
working on it in the w3c is now the
immersive web working group and they're
actually that's the they used to be the
immersive web interest group and the
difference between an interest and a
working group is that now their actual
charge is to publish a spec so that's
really exciting
and yeah so the the so that that's sort
of basically how we got to where we are
now right like we have that that it's
kind of unsatisfying right it's
basically I've said like there's a bunch
of problems and we're trying to solve
them but I think there's still some good
solutions that we've like come up with
so a frame is still really viable Google
has used it Google and Mozilla both have
used it for a bunch of different sort of
production projects you can do fancy
stuff like Network it you can recreate
you know drawing applications it's
really useful and really easy it's
designed for web designers and people
who sort of only know 2d JavaScript to
sort of get their feet wet with VR and
with WebGL so it's still really
accessible way which is and it's good to
see that there's so much support around
a VR a sort of immersive web library
like this Facebook has also gotten into
the game it used to be called react VR
but now it's just react 360 and it's
basically just a it's basically an API
that allows react to sort of handle and
gracefully
display 3d there sorry three yeah 3d and
360 video and photos so it's cool to see
that people are sort of building around
this technology and finally I think one
of the things that's most personally
exciting to me is that there's this
company called eighth wall that actually
just like launched their first thing for
the the spider-man release last year
their whole thing is like a web AR
marketing well ideally more applications
than marketing but marketing is a pretty
obvious one right now but yeah they so
this is there isn't you there's no one
there's no AR kit or a our core here
there's no sort of like on device API
being used it's all this is completely
running in Safari in the browser in a
normal standard browser so it's just
really cool to see that companies in you
know at the end of 2018 and sort of
going into 2019 are actually beginning
to invest in VR and they are
professionally and then there is some
also some exciting stuff sort of
happening already in 2019 around the
immersive web so the very first thing is
that just two days ago on February 5th
on Tuesday the first public draft
working draft of the WebEx our spec was
published and so what this means is that
basically now we're like on a track to
actually publishing a an actual web X
our spec which means it'll go to you
know the Safari that you know and love
and Firefox and Chrome and every other
browser and Samsung browsers and opera
etcetera etcetera right whatever browser
decides to implement it they can
implement it knowing that the API won't
all of a sudden change and you know
three months and then they'll have to
scrap a bunch of their engineering work
so it's really exciting to see the API
sort of reach maturity and along with
this it also means that like
experimental implementations that have
been built around the draft version of
the webex our API will hopefully get
better so there are a couple projects
one is from Google well there there's
there under two names but it's this
they're basically the same thing
fusing the Safari or the Chrome browser
on Android and iOS devices respectfully
to a 3GS session and so this really
gives you really really two accurate AR
capabilities with just a smartphone or
just an iPad as you can see in the gif
here and that those cubes are actually
rendered just using regular WebGL so
basically as long as you use this custom
browser you're able to sort of prototype
with what the webex our API could look
like and Mozilla has a similar effort
they actually published an iOS app that
makes this process super easy so you can
just make a normal web page and as long
as you visit it in this special little
iOS app or or custom compiled an Android
app you can sort of use regular WebGL or
3GS and and sort of begin to play around
with really experimental really sort of
spatial computing concepts and then yeah
so that's that's that's so basically all
that I have for the immersive web the
immersive web itself and I'm really
excited for sort of to see like to have
seen this like years long progression
into 2018 and 2019 but yeah so one last
thing is that I've actually just sort of
started a consulting business and I
don't actually want to have clients and
so basically I I'm putting this slide
here not for asking for work basically
if you're interested in the immersive
web if you want to learn more if you
want to talk to me this is a good way to
do it and have a bunch of free time now
so yeah if you can either reach me here
or at these other various places on the
internet yeah thank you
[Applause]
you
[Applause]